the first big snowfall of winter has
blanketed Belgrade with temperatures as
low as minus 20 it's no place to be
sleeping rough at night but for these
migrants the only shelter they can find
from the bitter cold is a disused
railway shed if you'll bring an animal
to these vir homes believe me that
animal will die we are humans so how we
will not die nineteen-year-old Sudha's
takes us inside even the migrants say
they don't feel safe amongst each other
here look at the life you cannot see the
air is thick with acrid smoke from the
fires they burn to try to bring light
and heat
most are young men from Afghanistan it's
a grim place for adults let alone
children but beneath the blankets who
find cousins who say they are aged 13
and 11 and are traveling alone I miss my
family says Serjeant
my mother father and brother what can I
do
it's very cold we have a lot of problem
says saying I'm itching
there are lice in my blanket there are
three warehouses like this in Belgrade
with more than a thousand migrants
sleeping rough in freezing conditions
some are too afraid to register with the
authorities for fear of being deported
others say they simply can't get any
help
this is belgrade's only government-run
camp migrants coming and going told us
it was overcrowded inside and new
arrivals are regularly turned away every
day they come in but but they don't
entering because because they tell us we
don't have any room empty here in
defiance of the Serbian authorities who
put pressure on aid agencies to stop
helping migrants in the city centre
there's a distribution of one hot meal a
day for those sleeping rough the
government believes charity will act as
a pull factor in a migration crisis
which is not its problem if your bear in
mind our limited resources from the
budget of the Republic of Serbia you can
conclude that this help should be bigger
and what we like at the moment and what
we like so far is this unique unified
European answer for all of us to tackle
this crisis many have spent months in
Serbia because the borders north into
Europe via Hungary and Croatia are
closed for these migrants the prospect
of that changing seems as bleak as the
freezing weather Lisa Holland sky knee
Belgrade